my next guest you know her from her news
special on netflix it's a one-man show
it's a special it's so much
more it's called nate natalie palomidas
thank you
for being here moses hey it's my first
candlelit interview this looks like
you're about to tell all i sure am
even without the candle i would i would
just spill my whole guts whatever you
want to ask me
i think you can relate to this a lot of
our stuff has to do with the audience
and being able to
in your case physically touch them yeah
get up in their face a lot of the heehee
hahas
are from oh my god she touched that man
i know that's my whole shtick
and now i can't touch anybody both my
solo shows are just me like
you know swap and spit with people and
grabbing their knockers etc etc you know
and you too you know yeah i mean i get a
lot much more
backlash for grabbing knockers but um
you gotta ask
yeah no it is like i talked to the
audience and i think if you're a
comedian that's always
like one-liners you don't need it then
you're fine you're able to roll into
this but to
not have the live feedback
oh man i was worried that your show was
not going to translate
to a special and it really did because
it is like
exactly what we're saying it is the live
aspect of being in the room
me personally i was like i hope she just
knows me too good that she doesn't call
on me
oh uh yeah you did it
no were you there were you at the taping
not at the taping no i
think i've been to three of the shows
when you were workshopping the show
oh my gosh thanks for coming i remember
very
uh very every time
i think of you i think about this bit
that you did with yarn where you're like
making a
sweater with the audience or something
is this accurate
yeah i was gonna say i remember it very
well but then i was like do i remember
it very well but that that's how i
remember
you whenever i think moses i think
making a sweater
beyond guy the yarn guy that's catboy
uh speaking of bits i cannot do in the
lockdown it's i'm connected to every
audience member
via a rope and then they can pull me
wherever and i try to do like a physical
bit or whatever and then they're
they're essentially like a puppet to
control manipulating you it's genius
it's genius
genius bit beautiful physical comedy but
not every venue
appreciates uh big physical
and even prop comedy um do you have any
stories of
venues that were mad because i think
about that now of like oh when you watch
a show like
some some stagehead has to clean that up
yeah well
you know i always try to be very
hands-on with my cleanups and try to
help
like the stagehands you know but that
sometimes doesn't always
uh you know make them less annoyed
but that they're always pretty nice i
remember at ucb
franklin which they've always been very
supportive there anyhow but i did i
flooded the stage
so in the netflix special i'm in a
bathtub
with the shower and but in
the live show that i just did myself diy
i just used a camping shower with a baby
pool
um underneath it and this particular
show at ucb
i didn't pull the baby pool fully
underneath
the shower and i just flooded the hole
underneath of the stage
and the artistic director was very nice
she was just like
hey you know you flooded the stage if
you do the show here again
you gotta make sure that the pool is
catching the water
and so i was like that's that's fair
that's fair and also i just i
i do cringe because nothing like kills
the bit and like apologizing for it
i know i know yeah but they're super
sweet is it something that you think
about now when you're workshopping
something of like oh i'm gonna have to
tour with this so maybe i can't well i
mean i've seen you breathe fire i was
gonna say breathe fire but you've done
that
yes in a very small venue that is
made if like the virgil is like if you
ask the fire department to build an
example of a fire hazard
it's low ceilings the dustiest curtains
and the curtains hang low too they hang
real low yeah so
this is probably like a dickish way to
go about
doing my stuff but i kind of operate
with
a apologize later kind of attitude
uh which you know probably
is not the best way you know maybe it's
like an [ __ ] way to go about doing
things and like
if i had caught the theater on fire that
would have [ __ ] set like i didn't i
didn't ask the producers if i could
do that right but if you did ask them
they wouldn't let you do it
yeah i've ripped down an entire curtain
back
back rod of a curtain you did hanging on
that i've broken the clock
on stage that looked expensive
uh that was the portland helium
and then it was at the kennedy center
and it was like older people
and it's like a 6 p.m show and i had the
rope sweater
thing that you're talking about yes and
uh
i i took someone out like it went across
her
her face like that like a rope burn oh
no
and i went back and they were like they
were she was cool about it and then i
went backstage to kind of like say thank
you to everyone that ran the venue and
kind of get like my pat's on the back
because it went well
yeah i just overheard them before i went
to the tech room they were like
what the hell was that
what the hell and i told him not to
climb on that stuff and i was just like
oh
it didn't feel cool it didn't feel like
i'm an artist it just felt
bad for them yeah they're like what the
[ __ ]
oh my god actually one time so me and
courtney perroso do this bit where
i play a dolphin trainer and she plays a
dolphin and that'll be
that's like yeah for that they have this
toxic relationship
and at the end of the bit she's sick of
him and so
i'm dangling a fish in front of her for
her to eat her treat
and she grabs it out of my hand and
starts beating me with the fish
so we're doing this show in edinburgh
scotland
have you you were no you told me to do
it but i i was going to
do it the twenty-two you were gonna do
it the 2020. yes exactly
okay i remember this but you were the
one that was pushing me to do it so
essentially you get to do your show
every night
for 30-ish days yeah exactly i think you
would kill it
anyway uh i was just there visiting
in 2019 and we were doing like a a bit
on a lineup show
and uh it was a midnight show
and everything in scotland closes at
like four o'clock or whatever
you know it's the height of the summer
there i go to the fishmonger at like
four o'clock
as late as i could to get this fish for
the bit
and it's just sitting in my backpack all
day you know
i think maybe in some ways it made the
bit a little more
punchy i made it a little bit more
effective it gave it like another kind
of factor that it
smelled just like rank
and when she beat me with the fish that
night and we ended up going they went
ran way over we ended up going up at
like 2 a.m
so this fish has been sitting in my
backpack scotland's summer
since 4 p.m it's 2 a.m she beats me with
it fish got to go flying everywhere all
over the theater and just like
is this a bigger fish if it's got guts
it's like what are we talking about yeah
we're talking about scottish yeah you
could hold it up in a photo scottish
mackerel you know i think it's a good
like 10 11 inches at least
yeah yeah and it's just you know we were
apologizing profusely afterwards because
the the theater just reeked
of fish and everybody does their shows
in there like the next day
all throughout the day and they were
doing everything they could
like blowing fans out the theater and uh
you know spraying febreze everywhere but
it didn't quite
resolve the issue it never went away and
you want it to go away you go back in
you're like let me smile it's probably
fine
yeah it doesn't leave yeah you get it
you get it
is there an entertainer that informed
the way you perform today
is there something you watch where
you're like i didn't know you could do
that because sometimes i watch your
stuff and i'm like oh i didn't know
you could do that and it just pushes me
in a in a direction to to experiment
more to try different things
oh thanks moses i think i would say the
same thing about you to be honest like
whenever
i watched your cat guy i was like whoa i
think brent weinbach was actually the
first person i saw
in john daly doing the drunk christmas
tree
yeah i was actually interning at conan
summer 2011
and i just went to like ucb and john
daley was doing his
sapity tappity drunk christmas tree and
my mind was blown
i was like whoa you can like just
go be a character and like interact with
people and just be [ __ ] dumb
and then i saw brent weinbach also at
ucb
and he was like doing some
weird [ __ ] bit where he was like
grinding on people in the audience not
not actually
touching them you know but in their face
and i was just like whoa
these guys are weird and um
they don't give a [ __ ] so nate you uh
he's on netflix right now
the response has been great it's been
cool to see people
see what everyone has seen for so many
years of you doing your own thing
carving out your own lane and now people
are sharing it and it seems like it's
doing pretty well
thanks moses i think people like it and
like you said i was also concerned that
it wouldn't
translate you know and then
you know cut some bits for time which
are also like
you know just like kills you inside but
yeah
i think all in all you know i i feel
like a lucky girl
you know it's like so cool and um
just to have it out there
is awesome and i can't yeah it's it's
crazy
it's crazy to go from like some black
box theater to like
on netflix people in uh you know chile
can watch it and stuff like that
how cool is that you know the chilean
market for you has been
insane we've hailed you as a deity there
it's been uh incredible i blew up in
chile i don't know what's going on but
i get a lot of dms from people in uh
chile you can say one thing to your
chile fans we got a lot in the comments
right now
chile is going off they actually want
you to get involved in politics like
they said pick a side i don't that means
anything to you
i say uh no comment right now comment
right now
ah not comment right now um every minute
i wish i knew how to say that in spanish
um but yeah no comment aura and uh
come back to me uh later
later we watched the special thank you
natalie uh hopefully you can stick
around for a little bit
after but uh nate is on netflix right
now
highly recommend it thank you moses
you